for many Avid video game fans those who
just can't get enough of grinding away
for hours on quests battling endless
enemies and exploring infinite Virtual
Worlds Landing a job as a gameplay
tester seems like the perfect
opportunity doing your favorite thing in
the world and getting paid to do it well
that's the dream plus the added benefit
of seeing how the sausage gets made of
getting access to a game still in
development and suggesting ways it can
be improved think of all the gaming
disasters that might have been avoided
with a few more play testers in the room
looking at you Fallout New Vegas and
your NPCs with the spinning heads well
One Gamer had the same thought a young
man by the name of Danny wheeler when he
spotted an ad seeking beta play testers
for an in-development RPG from an
up-and-coming indie game Studio he
jumped at the chance to apply the pay
wasn't amazing but it was definitely a
better gig than his current job at the
local convenience store Hawking energy
drinks to snarky teens and Counting down
the hours until he could get back home
kick up his feet and get away from it
all with a controller in his hand but
sometimes things that seem too good to
be true actually are at first Danny had
a perfectly enjoyable time testing the
game it was standard RPG fantasy fodder
and though he made sure to inform the
developers that he found the steampunk
aesthetic to be a little bit played out
at this point there was nothing at all
notable about it it was fine but the
development team kept going on and on
about the Tactical heuristic algorithms
and how the game was meant to learn the
more the player played so Dany was
instructed to log as many hours of this
exceedingly average game as possible he
sat at his desk for hours sipping on an
extra large soda and clicking away
fighting Orcs goblins and more slowly
the difficulty began to increase and the
game started to grow on him a bit he
even developed a favorite character to
play as the Rogue with his stealth and
proficiency for close range combat the
more he played as the Rogue however the
more he started to notice the game's
characters behaving differently enemies
were attacking him with ranged weapons
from far away they were setting traps to
ruin his character's stealthy approach
and catch him in the ACT then the game
started to glitch a lot to the point of
becoming nearly unplayable enemies would
fall to the ground as if Dead when he
hadn't dealt them a single blow as he
started to walk his characters away from
them they would suddenly spring back to
life and strike before he could even
think about a defense if he didn't know
any better he could swear the game's
characters were deliberately trying to
trick him it only got more frustrating
from there with enemies making sudden
loud sounds to catch him off guard and
startle him out of concentration and
other characters staring down the barrel
of the camera with serious unblinking
eyes as if they could see him through
his monitor one day he fired up the game
to see that its characters somehow had
rearranged various torches to spell out
you'll never amount to anything Annie
your dad was right it took a ton of
torches and Danny couldn't help but take
it personally that was the last straw he
returned the game to the studio and
resigned from his position he got enough
insults working in customer service he
didn't need to take that kind of talk
from a video game though he didn't know
it Dany got out not a moment too soon
other play testers were not as lucky
particularly One Man Who Would sadly
lose his life as Danny intuited this was
no ordinary video game it was unusual
enough to draw the attention of the SCP
Foundation who would go on to designate
it
scp-1633
scp-1633 is an anomalous computer game
created by a now defunct independent
game Studio the copy currently being
held by the foundation is believed to be
a beta version of the game while the
core gameplay is relatively complete
there are numerous missing assets the
music is largely either missing or
placeholder music and the game is
plagued by a large number of graphical
glitches because of the generally buggy
and glitchy nature of the game the
foundation considered both Todd Howard
and CD projekt Red to be major people
and groups of interest in the case
however the discovery of other key
suspects eventually absolved them of
Suspicion for now this version of the
game was compiled two days before the
foundation raided the office of the
studio and is therefore believed to be
the most complete version of the game in
existence to be more specific about the
actual nature of the game itself
scp-1633 is a squad-based RPG with a
third person camera perspective the
action is seen from an elevated
perspective with all characters on
screen aesthetically the game world is
steampunk and features various fantasy
creatures as enemies including elves
dwarves Orcs goblins Etc fitting with
the steampunk style the game's urban
areas are modeled after Victorian era
London the four player characters are a
band of Outlaws hired by the Sinister
Archduke of odrick to investigate a
theft however as the game progresses it
becomes a battle to save the entire
world as an ancient all-powerful being
known as krathnar intends to wake from
its Thousand-Year Slumber and Destroy
Humanity the player controls a squad of
four characters with direct control over
one character at a time and a command
menu to control the other three It is
believed that in the game's Finnish
State a multiplayer option that would
have allowed four different real world
players to cooperate is likely to have
been included like many squad-based
games each character has a different
specialty The Marksman uses long-range
weapons The Alchemist has access to
potions and chemicals with various
defects the road can move stealthily and
assassinate enemies and the thug has
greater Health than the other characters
and does more melee damage and as is
also typical for games of this variety
XP earned from completing challenges and
killing enemies throughout the game
allows for players to upgrade the
abilities and stats of their characters
while the story and core gameplay
mechanics are nothing special there is
one element that pushes
scp-1633 into anomalous territory and
it's also the element that would have
been front and center in the finished
games marketing campaign it's quote
tactical heuristic algorithms these work
in a unique fashion whenever a player
finishes a session and saves their game
the game will begin running lengthy
background processes when these
processes are complete a ptd or player
tactical data file is saved on the
computer when the save file and by
extension the associated ptd file is
loaded the enemies and challenges in the
game will have become far more effective
tailoring their methods to the
particular skills and tactics of the
player the extent to which this happened
is proportional to the amount of time
spent playing the game this kind of
Technology may seem theoretically
possible but the extent to which the
game pushes it causes it to rest in
anomalous territory the game's
programming is so intelligent that I can
tell simply by the tiniest clues in your
play style if you're loading a file that
isn't your own it will then pause the
game and make you load your own save
file and the tactics employed by the
enemies in the game as they learn more
about the player are nothing short of
frightening at first the enemies will
adapt to the player's preferred weapons
strategies and overall play style then
they will realize that the player
character is controlled by an external
Force meaning of course you and begin to
mount psychological attacks directly on
the player through numerous tests the
foundation has been able to build a kind
of framework for the average player
experience through this framework we're
able to track and correlate average play
time with the average adaptability of
scp-1633 to the player it is worth
noting that these effects do not apply
if the game is completed in a single
continuous playthrough for the purposes
of this experiment the game was stopped
saved and restarted at regular inner
intervals allowing the game to collect
player tactical data during the first
two hours the game's AI is abysmal with
enemies simply charging at the players
with no strategy whatsoever and
typically being mowed down however from
two to five hours the enemies undergo
intelligence growth adapting their play
style to the types of weapons they carry
and their environments at this stage
this combat level is also about equal to
an untrained human civilian from five to
eight hours enemies become considerably
more proficient and then begin
countering the player on their specific
play Styles and techniques for example
they will attack a player who uses
long-range Weaponry from cover with
grenades or Splash damage weapons to
force them out into the open they will
also fully utilize their environment for
both defensive and offensive purposes
laying traps and creating ambushes to
surprise and kill players at this point
their combat skills are equal to trained
soldiers from 8 to 12 hours the focus of
the enemy shifts from attacking the
player character to attacking the player
directly they engage in behaviors that
from an online playing perspective would
be considered griefing such as
intentionally blocking the player's view
or movement within the game enemies have
also been known to exploit player
expectations pretending to be broken or
glitched to make the player let their
guard down and then killing them in one
play session the enemies begin throwing
day flash spells similar to real life
flashbang grenades at the player they
throw them in a manner that created a
strobing effect causing the player to
have a grand mal seizure Beyond 12 hours
the enemies engage in advanced
psychological tactics against the player
with methods that range wildly and tend
to be specific to the player's mindset
and play style for example one player
likes to exert a high level of control
over all four of their squad members in
response enemies used attacks that did
little or no damage but caused the
characters to become
a state which temporarily disrupts
player control however rather than
attack the dazed characters enemies
simply surround them in a crowd
continually using day's attacks to
prevent the player from doing anything
this caused major frustration for the
player enemies may also attempt to
induce psychological Terror among the
players in one example enemies somehow
kidnapped one of the four-player
characters and dragged them off screen
when this character was later found they
were strapped to a kind of sacrificial
altar this caused considerable anxiety
for the player it seems that this is the
upper limit of the game's anomalous
powers in most cases meaning things
typically level off after 12 hours
unless a specific entity appears to be
inhabiting the game which you'll learn
more about later in order to discover
the prior information the SCP Foundation
performed a series of tests on the game
with various different subjects in test
001 Junior researcher Ross an
experienced gamer who was pivotal in
first discovering the anomaly skipped
ahead of the typical preliminary d-class
tests seeing as he was already eager for
the game's non-anomalous release he was
also eager to be the first in line to
try it out on the foundation's dime
being a gamer Ross also found a number
of glitches and exploits in the game to
improve his performance allowing him to
run rings around his enemies however as
expected the enemies adapted to Ross's
techniques after Gathering his player
tactical data first they just began
using their weapons and exploiting the
environments more effectively but they
didn't stop there soon they became aware
of the same exploits Ross was using
before exploiting them themselves and
using it to beat him repeatedly in the
end they moved to the psychological
stage forcing Ross into a glitch that
rendered him unable to move he tried to
free his character for several minutes
until realizing he couldn't and rage
quit the game in test 002 they used a
d-class designated d
22930 he was a man with proven anger
issues even down to murdering his prior
girlfriend in a jealous rage initially
he enjoyed the game choosing the thug
character type and taking out his
aggression on the many enemies however
as time went on the enemies became wise
to his tactic he began their
psychological attacks they gathered
around the d-class's player character
dropping their weapons but the Swarm
became so tightly packed around the
character that he couldn't even move
this started to cause major frustration
when the character attempted to charge
through the enemies attacked killing him
with their bare hands in test014 the
foundation brought in an agent with
special forces experiences with Advanced
knowledge in tactical combat however
even she was worn down and defeated over
time as the enemies adapted to and
exploited her tactics the foundation
even considered using scp-1633 as a tool
for developing effective counter-tactic
in their real life operations in test 0
to 1 the foundation used a d-class with
vast experience in the world of
commercial gaming he was told to
complete the game in one playthrough
taking pauses rather than proper breaks
as predicted with no time to run the
background processes and create player
tactical data files the enemies weren't
able to improve and the d-class was able
to complete the game in around 13 hours
however the game did create a player
tactical data file in the aftermath of
this playthrough and used it to offer a
new game plus mode to the d-class when
he began to play this new game the
screen displayed a seemingly random
pattern of black and white pixels
visually similar to television static
this image appeared to be Cognito
hazardous as it caused Catatonia and
later death for the player in what felt
like a decidedly Petty move for
scp-1633 as alluded to earlier the game
was first discovered by Junior
researcher Ross who was an avid follower
of the independent game Studio initially
producing the game however while
frequenting developer fan forums he
found that various members of the team
were quitting the project for seemingly
bizarre reasons while this wasn't enough
on its own for the foundation to
intervene it was what first attracted
official attention they moved in after
the death of Gregor Tillman a game
tester for the company who died not long
after joining the project the foundation
moved in and after that gained control
shutting down the studio and taking
everything they had all anomalous
elements were isolated secured and
contained any loose ends were given
amnestics and recorded data on the
anomalous artifacts were destroyed it's
believed that one classified female
member of the dev team was behind the
anomalous nature of the game but she was
able to escape and has since attempted
to join other development teams she is
now considered an active person of
interest and is being pursued by mobile
task force mu 6 AKA don't hate the
player some final disturbing details are
recorded in a note left by the game
tester Gregor Tillman the note seized by
the foundation and included in
scp-1633's official file reads as
follows I'm writing this on paper
because I don't think he can learn it he
got everything digital real quick but
I've unplugged the router and broke my
phone so I think he's trapped in here
but he won't stop talking talking all
the time at the start of this job they
told me all about the Tactical algorithm
stuff man I've been playing games all my
life and I knew I could beat it I I knew
I could handle this when I started
playing the game they learned quickly I
kept using the sniper rifle and after
like an hour they learned how to use
cover in another couple hours and they'd
set ambushes another hour and they
started sniping back while having a
different Squad flank me after that they
figured out how to glitch the physics
engine and ride crates at me or duck
under the floor they were learning but
all that was just easy stuff it was
Evolution then one bit figure something
out so it survive lives longer than the
others it wasn't directed after act 3
krathnar shows up he's supposed to be
like this Lovecraft Cosmic horror Crazy
Monster who can read the player's mind
and corrupt your soul he showed up right
after I killed strict the blood Drinker
that big spider monster he's supposed to
have this long speech about how I killed
his General on this plane and now he
needs to intervene directly or something
but instead he talked about how I was a
worthy adversary but I was cheating
because I was on another plane crather
wasn't like the other enemies because he
wasn't supposed to be he was supposed to
be smart he was supposed to know
everything so he did he'd been watching
his minions fight me the whole time and
he knew everything they did it wasn't
just random mutations anymore it was
planned it was an evolution man it was
actual intelligent design I brought it
home I had to know more I'm sorry but I
had to I copied the latest compile and
installed it on my home box and brought
my save game and that other file with me
on a flash drive it was the same there
he kept talking to me about how I was
keeping him fulfilling his purpose by
keeping him trapped in a glass jar no
matter where I went in the game he kept
shouting and ranting then he did more
but first it was just slowing down in my
other programs the drive chugging when
it shouldn't be then the next time I
played the game he started talking about
my screenplays while the enemies looked
like me I guess he could see through the
webcam he started needling me about
Jenny reading me bits of her emails
acting out the breakup he found the
videos of her and started making the
enemies talk at her voice then it was
everywhere in my computer I uninstalled
the game but he was still there he kept
opening documents and typing to me
calling me a foul cheat and a lowly worm
telling me to fight him on the same
plane as soon as I realized he was
outside the game I shut down my router
pulled out the network card but I don't
know if I got them quickly enough maybe
he got out and turned the computer off
but he kept turning it back on I wanted
to break it but I didn't know if that
would kill him maybe it wouldn't maybe
it would let him out I tried leaving the
house but it was like I could still hear
him I couldn't leave him alone because
he might get out or do something else I
can't sleep haven't slept since he came
out I've been here for three days and I
can't leave I can't leave him he keeps
telling me to release him but I can't I
want to kill him but I don't know if I
can I I can't think anymore I have to
kill kill kill him before he does
anything new he won't stop talking and I
can't keep thinking I can't keep going
I'm sorry I have to go now I'm sorry I'm
sorry after studying the note carefully
the foundation conducted a thorough
investigation for any other
manifestations of this crothner entity
no mentions of it were found on any of
the other devices in Tillman's apartment
nor did a web search on the subject turn
up any relevant results at this time it
is believed that the entity whatever it
was or whatever it was attempting to do
was destroyed along with Tillman's
computer which he appeared to have taken
apart smashed and burned in a metal
trash can whatever tormented him during
his last days on Earth is gone now
thankfully because the foundation
currently owns the only copy of the game
and the game's anomalous effects are
only evident to active players
scp-1633 poses no risk of containment
breach and therefore it has been given
the object class safe one copy of
scp-1633 is stored on a standard DVD ROM
in a secure storage locker in site 15
along with all supporting documentation
and ancillary materials any any
playthroughs of the game must be
approved by project head Dr Berger and
all have said playthroughs are to be
monitored closely and subject to strict
rules after all this is one game that
doesn't play fair now go check out
scp-5167 when the Imposter is sus God I
can't believe we did that episode and
the deadliest game
scp-1918 tic-tac-toe for more of the
world's deadliest games